hey guys I recently had a question about
alkaline water what did I think about it
so I wanted to do a quick video on that
okay now normally when you buy certain
types of bottled water or artesian water
or well water or spring water it comes
alkalyn okay but the reason why it's
alkaline is because of the alkaline
minerals magnesium calcium and potassium
and other minerals as well that's what
makes it alkalyn okay and also by
carbonates which is alkaline so that's a
good thing but when you actually have a
machine that makes your water alkaline
it's not by adding minerals it's by
splitting apart the water molecules with
electricity to artificially make the
water alkaline now in 29 years of
practice I have had quite a few people
come in that have used the alkaline
water okay and I have a machine that
measures the pH in the urine and I would
notice that a high percentage of these
people would come in with a pH of 9 in
the urine now normally in the urine it
should be 5 or 6 but never this high 9 9
is really alkaline okay now the problem
with having your urine being that high
in a pH that alkaline is that you don't
have any protection against the microbes
so microbes can grow in the body a lot
more
it's one of the purposes of having
acidic urine so we can kill off the
microbes so I do know that alkaline
water does alter chemistry in not a good
way there's three fluids in the body
that normally should be acid the stomach
which should be extremely acid the large
bowel and the urine okay and those
fluids need to be acid for a reason even
the stomach should be acid for a reason
to help you break down protein to help
you absorb minerals and also to kill
microbes so when you consume alkaline
water which is unnatural to the body it
can neutralize the different acidic
fluids in the body and that can create
problems with digestion large bowel
which is digestion and even your urine
as well so your my
Propst can actually increase also it's
going to affect the absorption of
electrolytes and your heart is the key
organ that needs these key electrolytes
in the right balance so if you're going
to neutralize the ph and throw up the
electrolytes it could create a problem
with the heart so that's a long answer
to I would not recommend alkaline water
make sure you if you want out the water
and get it naturally alkaline not
artificially thanks for watching hey you
know what I just want to say something
only thirty percent of the people that
watching this video actually make it
this far and you did so I really
appreciate you thank you so much